those holding the guns very definitely
hold the power now
many have fought all their lives for
this
growing up killing and battling those
they call infidels yet now they tell us
they're ready for peace
but the fighters also revel in their
battlefield victories boasting to us
about killing countless americans
did you kill
them
[Music]
it was war so i don't know how many i
killed there were too many to count once
a bomb landed and it didn't explode we
made five mines out of it and blew five
of their armored vehicles to pieces how
do you feel about killing other other
people
it was jihad holy war and in islam we
don't regret this
but after two decades the taliban have
new pr and the updated image is one
where they talk peace to a female
foreign journalist
praise god our behavior is very good now
we've changed a lot we are polite
manners are good and our behavior is
much improved we're much better than the
last government kabul is safe now
to show how progressive they now are
they agreed to take us on a short patrol
but our arrival particularly that of a
strange female prompts near panic
amongst the foot soldiers who
immediately disembark
they're finding the new approach an
entirely unsettling one
we accompany them anyway much to their
obvious discomfort but afghanistan's new
rulers know they need to show they've
moved on
the taliban want to show that they're in
control they're desperate for the
recognition from the international
community
few are entirely convinced in
afghanistan now it's good not bad
but just the women are not coming
outside the houses
and people some people are worrying
because the
taliban
have a bad future before
are you worried
yes
and convincing the world they've changed
may be the taliban's hardest battle alex
crawford sky news kabul